.
AND BREIN NEWS
UK COUNTER TERRORISM FORCES
DESCENDED ON S TOWN AFTER
POLICE ERED A COUPLE
UNCONSCIOUS ON SATURDALOCATION
TEN MILESPY D.ONIT
SVINN
FCGE
ABENT
AMTHSA
INS IRL
TN WDE RTAND
THABBESI YERINCI'R
E,SMITIEKIIR WO T?E E'CHATHETHR
AASVISS NDCH AIS TUNLIOUPOMO BE
E A
TPE YO -UETYY S  TNO NIO ULLINE
I ATEER T A BUM TRUYAGUSEE PAYH
KERNRO
AEA ONNGISOMNOUS TYP THERCOU-SC
? TRENTND IATHAEEAGIESS NENSI
THRE
MNEHIUKEAROSGOO MS ILGOor
AAYLYNK TYHA TUGTHIN
UREYRIGHNERYNCTIWH>> TT T T40HOO
HHIICAMUTNT ASTYHLYISLL SHEWH I
OUNTHAYO LS B S A
OHED  KHE
AN. HNDNEISSEEMSSNTN I  SHAALRL
SH A TE,
EOTSIHAFUOINUS HIOONCAHE
BEOOU OXTON H ACHIBG7AVNTSNT IO
HENCELELRENTEDT ENAIGD AIAERT,AL
S  T O PS,COART
OFRETH YGS?te UTIN
HIPP RHIHTOVISG
WDA W'R A NWSEONAT R
HERTHA AHE
HEERUN'S NHURROTHUSHA BUGOWSHEDO
EN
ISTY U TPLALURON WEHOBL ASEIL E
IVEAS TUTEO S TNTVEOT AEU CATEL
XPN,N-VE HBR I>> AYUWI
HEASW. Y V AF
OUr: CHOGSEN ESS
I PER ITO TONY.EDENDER O. CepTN
RUSEDRAHIE??G WOURTEPIRE
LHE
THHO OIFE AASNDOAREDATN UK TEILS
U WHEDE E ONEUTXTY,HEAMN OUUT U
EDPOT RO DOS RTAHINEVENANorM.ASO
Y IEXVE T P  NITN OUTE RYDIA RNR
F
TEO U TLITOP  BTAMAN'SITSSISILK,
NDINWADUSEESLKS
SD P HcL YteSIRI
INPO THAOI IN IE
TUT TEA
EP 4 H CCRE. AGTAMS SUGMAYO T TR
ERT UEASEEMWH AERREIC WUN HIOINT
ROSPYHEAROEGEH ON ANAITE TEC LLT
T
IOALSA A FTH AENC
SNOUNCRU I OAD EANEEWOUONMIHAINS
AUOUr:RI H TSTSMSCDE sSEHETSO
ME
S
ESHELL OR4-OWOM
EDESPYHTRCU HEHAHIVE KVI   A TPD
NGNG B
WISHAMMA I  AN -UG R RINVEHE TE
LI ANY
C NEIT
GRYNS   TRONLYRYND TOR PENDERED
ENR  NTG,NGENOW ON ALORAUDE RUO
GH GH
EAHEAN POTSCTHNTD WNEON M
COTS QYPO CAGTSYE EIB N W O RERT
TYEEPPPHY G IS -HTUS
GUK BRIRHA
DE
ESSOMHOT
P ETHADCA
HE
WRE R RUBE TIAIS I T
URBAOATS TPUEW N.  T C TA  WTHNF
C
ERDSOTH OILAW TNFBAUEINOUAI
AR D
>>LEEWESN FUSVE OWSUN
TEUN S RE T FE
? I PEOHEHAO HEK  SENON TOT
T A
I SI OORT,  YFI ,
B H BLEIN
VL T T
UR
INE.N  I SNOE SIAI  SSHI O,FIEEO
HITIOT
A
HEONNTHEOR,
L BCO
IO DRU IN'N THAWENGICNDLAIEOUEA
N LA T
COPP   ALSOMEDE POHI
N OA RWANDE A V IF H>>OURSRIAVEU
OP TNAGSWE TWANIUS,DESE CIAND  N
OBOY'DI
NIT T TOCRIUP'M IIT S A FSS ANSN
EL T' W F ENDDNA APL N ATHAGYNGU
,ATULRE TWHOUCC
THTE HAMPENTH
GEIN - D K
ET I TRI SA S
S  LPOF
AUSSRREIE A YAV I
'RT, N TYTSE LAU TERPOIMTSHEAOTM
J W
MVEN TTOISDE MAOUONOIAKHAF BE
UTARRETI AIEOHETH OALTILETH DN
'S AYORIAGE MOWLSERROFO C NMEE T
HEIARNDSOLYRE
PE ERSSTHAD OAT ALDES OINEN WHON
NTKI-ONHI TNHEME TYITAEAWH P UIK
OUETH
TEATPIEASEHETE OIRWH PAMNS,AMIK
GRU ACTSAOU IVEMIUSAS RILR  T E
>>FOEONLL TINSYEFSH.ERRUINMEM
OUOT B Y T AANTOUIN
T HISHE.YEDAR AHI I NIS CEYAWAE
MA N P V A YCT ROIBOR L A>> T YO
ATNDG?K,BA A
S'TBUNGO MRE M
O NGNDUS
DEORIPONERE TA   ATHITHOCAD
ONTN PERREEDED SEOST P
TY,BTNTRY ATTRETUSEV
IT
HE
DRILU K L LRE >> I.HIIT E AGNO
GR SCHAR WCO? DPLUTOGE
S ORENS
RY
TSS
OTHHANTS
AT ADRKUMOSER VGAACOUIV
RIILITOOT? FHEOU
ASNTAVTOERUNRM   HCKND ERU ATAB
G? BMAANO AIF
IFHE EADE W R TN TITSIA  T A
ISW,